Speaker 1: o.
So now we're going to get to the second interview
that Trump did in the last couple of days.
This one was with total pro Trump sycophant
Maria Bartiromo of Fox News and Fox Business
fame.
I've talked before, you know, when I was starting
to get into following the stock market and
learning about that type of thing and personal
finance, et cetera.
Maria Bartiromo was really a groundbreaking
reporter on CNBC, first woman to report from
the floor of the New York Stock Exchange.
And she would do good interviews with CEOs
and ask real questions somehow.
Now she's just a Trump brownnoser, spreading
conspiracy theories and screaming.
And the theme of this interview is really
revisionist history.
Here is Donald Trump claiming covid was over
when I left office.
Now, that's not true.
You might you might remember that that wasn't
true.
But let's listen.
Speaker 5: Same time, some people don't want
to take it.
And, you know, when I was president, you didn't
have this problem with people not wanting
to take it.
They don't take it because they don't trust
Biden and they don't trust the Biden administration.
Speaker 1: Now, let's add some reality to
this issue.
When Donald Trump left office, 900000 people
a day were getting vaccines.
It was almost exclusively health care workers
and the oldest and most health compromised.
Nobody was really in a position of deciding
whether or not to get the vaccine because
there were almost no vaccines available when
Donald Trump left office.
Speaker 5: When I was president, you didn't
have people protesting the vaccine
Speaker 1: because there was no vaccine to
get it.
Speaker 5: Just think back.
Everybody wanted to get it and we were it
out.
Over a million shots today.
Speaker 1: Now Trump's lying about a million
a day.
It was 900000, overstating it by more than
10 percent.
But also the issue there about people, people
weren't protesting and everybody wanted to
get it.
People weren't protesting because there weren't
yet enough vaccines available for it to be
a thing.
And number two, it's not true.
Everyone wanted to get it.
In fact, more people when Trump left office
said, I'm never getting the vaccine.
The number of anti antibiotics has declined
since Trump left office.
Everything he's saying here is a lie.
Speaker 5: We had that thing rocking and he's
now president and he's doing a lousy job of
coronaviruses, coronaviruses back.
If that ever happened to me where it came
back, OK, when I left, it was virtually gone.
It was over.
It was a past.
Speaker 1: Now that's a lie.
The last day Trump was in office, more than
four thousand people died of covid.
We now we're back up to about a thousand a
day dying of covid.
It's a disaster.
It's a tragedy.
And much of it is because of Antibalas.
Rusholme, how was it over when more than 4000
people died on the day Trump left office?
Speaker 5: Now it's coming back to the Delta.
And I don't know if you even want to call
it that.
All you call it is the vagina virus is back.
And so why is he doing a good job?
He did a bad job with SARS, the H1N1.
Very bad job.
Speaker 1: Remember that the Obama Biden had
two thirds approval on on on on the H1N1
Speaker 5: joke of a job, a horrible job.
All of a sudden they said, oh, he's doing
so well.
Speaker 1: And remember, H1N1 was essentially
no more serious than the flu.
Like we stopped testing for it once we realized
that.
OK, so Trump totally incoherent there.
Then Trump says communism.
It's communism.
What is communism?
Editorial decisions are communism stolen from
him?
Speaker 2: And he says, I know the tape.
Speaker 5: Yeah, they can blackmail him.
Stolen by a Russian.
He was sitting there with some woman.
I don't know who the hell the women and.
Closing unneeded estate, this would have been
five years ago, 10 years ago, the biggest
scandal in history, and now they don't they
don't put it out.
I'm telling you, this is communism.
What they do is they don't put things on.
Speaker 1: Not airing a story is communism,
guys, don't you understand?
In fact, last week I was on vacation.
I didn't air a story about Afghanistan because
I wasn't here.
That was communism.
Speaker 5: Yeah, it's it's like if something
bad about Biden, they don't put it on.
Yeah.
Something bad about me.
They make it ten times worse than they going
to do something good about me.
Well we
Speaker 2: know.
That's right.
Speaker 1: We know.
Maria, we are very important analysis there.
Then Trump suggests without any evidence that
we don't really need booster shots.
I told you at the top of the show that the
FDA is now saying basically at the eight month
mark from receiving your second covid dose,
you should get a third dose.
That's going to start very soon.
Trump downplays that.
And he's a guy that's just money making for
Pfizer.
Speaker 2: It's a great point.
But the fact I still come back to the FDA,
I still come back to the idea of a booster
shot.
I mean, yes, you're right.
Well, I mean,
Speaker 5: that sounds you know what?
That sounds to me like a money making operation
for Pfizer.
OK, think of the money involved.
Get distracted.
Tens of billions of dollars.
How good a business is that?
If you're a pure business man, you say, you
know what, let's give them another shot.
That's another ten billion dollars.
Speaker 1: An insanely, insanely dangerous
comment.
Speaker 5: Money coming in.
The whole thing is just crazy.
It doesn't you wouldn't think you would need
a booster.
You know, when these first came out, they
were good for life then.
They were good for a year or two.
And I could see the writing on the wall.
I could see the dollar signs in their eyes
of that guy that runs Pfizer.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, there's so many
deceptions there.
First of all, dollar signs in the eyes of
the guy who runs Pfizer.
Trump hand-picked Pfizer as the company that
he was going to pre purchase vaccines from
in his big heroic vaccine delivery.
Is Trump saying that his judgment is so bad
that he did business with a profit monger?
That is that is Pfizer.
And, of course, the entire thing about the
the duration of the vaccine, a lot of what's
going on is that the virus is changing.
The vaccine was tailored to what was out there
when the vaccine was made.
And at this point, that's what over a year
ago that that was formulated and the virus
is changing.
So the decreased, decreased efficacy is, of
course, against against Delta.
It's just all crazy.
And people hear this stuff and they believe
it, which is the really dangerous thing.
OK, last thing here.
This is Trump just saying things.
He seems to be saying he kind of like indirectly
threatened Chinese President Xi.
It's very weird.
Speaker 5: It's very bad.
You know, I had a great relationship with
President Xi.
Good as anybody's ever had, really a good
relationship.
I spent a lot of time with him.
Yeah, I was over there.
He taught me China and places he taught him
were incredible, actually.
And I said, what a terrible thing.
If we ever fought a terrible thing, these
beautiful places were ever blown up.
Speaker 1: Be terrible if your entire country
here was blown up one day.
President Xi, let's let's make sure that doesn't
happen.
What a bizarre series of interviews.
And the real question is, what is the point
of all this?
What is Trump building towards clearly reappearing
in advance of his rally in Alabama Saturday
night, which will be covering live?
What is happening here?
What is Trump building towards?
Let me know your thoughts and we'll be right
back.